uh we have a big announcement to make so
there will be another CE 240 6A
um web3 entrepreneurship next quarter uh
winter quarter uh it will be also a
speaker series so we'll have a lot of uh
really interesting uh speakers like uh
some of the most prominent speakers in
with three space
uh give talks on different topics
um some of the most interesting topics
in that three a little bit different
than this quarter is probably going to
have a little bit more kind of a deep
dive into some of the topics and also
some of the topic will be a little more
technical we just assume some of the
folks already taking classes like a
tamponade's class our class is quarter I
already have some kind of exposure to
crypto either from the business
perspective or from the technical
perspective
so sign up right now I think you can
register so
um so just to start I want to uh kind of
repeat the thesis we had before
um you know last year there's a lot of
money flowing to this um new industry
weather industry I received more than 30
billion dollars and and racing at the
extremely high evaluation for a very
early stage startups
um and then
um we uh the course or the the aim of
the course is to um evaluate like this
new industry uh to see which aspect of
this industry is more like um
um like uh going to create a long
lasting and a positive glow impact and
we just aspect a more like a bubble and
um
and uh right now we're actually using
this lecture to kind of reflect
something we learned along the way with
the lectures from different guest
speakers and see which part is actually
a bubble and which part more like a long
lasting would change change the world
and change the future
so this is a bit of agenda so we'll go
over the blocking fundamentals and use
cases and then I'm going to evaluate all
the different aspects it's like a
blockchain D5 EFT and the Dows and to
see which is real and which is more like
a bubble
with that I'll pass on to Gil
so I'm not going to give you guys
in economics give us crowdsource
decentralized Tech platforms right
without a single point of failure and
ultimately we have a distributed Ledger
that's the technology and distributed
compute so that there isn't a single
point of failure you've got consensus to
make sure that you have honest actions
uh and you have cryptography which is
kind of like a timestamp assuring your
history and you have economics to
incentivize to incentivize everyone to
uh uh to appropriately either
participate or actually like run this
platform but really what is this
enabling right so if we think about
blockchain as open protocols right so
this is a bit of an eyesore uh supposed
to build
um but if you think about infrastructure
right you can move things you can hold
and transfer things you can own things
you can have identity you can decide
what's truth in the physical world these
are all defined by governments and local
standards in the digital world we don't
have any of that so in the digital world
you have all of these walled Gardens if
you think about like AOL IBM and novel
in the the 60s 70s and 80s you have
these internets you could speak to other
people on AOL with aim but no one else
you could speak to the people within
your company as soon as we connected all
of these with open protocols uh HTTP FTP
email right that created the internet so
having Open Standards and open protocols
is really where this value is that
people can build on top of that uh in a
similar way you don't actually they own
or transfer any of your money your Banks
do right you ask your bank to transfer
money via Zell or ACH and if your bank
disappeared your money is theoretically
gone it might be insured by the
government right PayPal and venmo
similarly uh whereas as soon as you
connect all of these into a common
standard a common platform and protocol
now you owned your own money and you're
transferring your own money right you
don't own your own health records you
don't own your own stocks right if you
can create these platforms
and these open protocols that enables an
entirely new class of things I don't
know if you guys remember when Facebook
had all these games that people were
building on it uh farm bill and whatnot
and then at some point they all stopped
building all this crap why because
Facebook would either copy them or
change their code so as soon as you have
like a fragmented wall Garden you don't
control a platform you don't want to
build on that platform anymore as soon
as you have Open Standards now anyone
can build really interesting things and
it creates entire classes of things
right and this is true for identity
where you have hundreds of identities
that you don't control it's true for
Truth where you can't even decide what's
true anymore and companies like chain
link and other oracles are trying to use
consensus to Define what is actually
real in the world programmatically
so now if we take a look at like
blockchain strengths and weaknesses
what's it good at right multi-party
coordination because it's open and
permissionless anyone can come in and
out it's immutable right so multiple
parties we don't trust each other have a
single source of Truth uh right there's
built-in trust so it's Caesar and
censorship resistant you have to you
have to worry about the the platform
disappearing all of a sudden it's
privacy preserving so you can use it and
feel comfortable using it with things
like theoretically your health records
your personal records Etc
right and we have all these new
behaviors in the world where we don't
actually trust our institution so having
a trusted platform in theory is really
valuable there's built-in Finance right
which is both the new channel for
communication as well as incentive
structures it creates all these new
business models like web payments where
you know if you think about the only
actual uh business models that really
work or subscription models uh and AD
models why because payments are hard and
full of friction if payments become
frictionless all of a sudden that opens
tons of new business models uh uh
right so if we look at where it's weak
performance it's really slow
um right and even on l2s where you have
like settlement times and challenges
there it's expensive and even when it's
not expensive it's because utilization's
kind of low who knows uh how expensive
it'll really be as soon as you get to
like uh High utilization but it's also
heavily influenced by speculation the
user experience is really crappy who
wants to remember private keys to do
anything
uh right the developer experience is
really crappy if you think of the iPhone
uh I wasn't the first smartphone the
iPhone made all the difference because
it made it really easy for someone who's
non not super technical to develop
applications so if you're trying to
develop something for a bank you don't
need to know the the details of a
smartphone in a similar way if we can
get to a place where uh you can develop
like that in web 3 a lot more people
will be able to develop until then we're
stuck with only people that are actually
like really heavily uh knowledgeable in
web3 development able to develop
anything
uh uh right so uh by definition uh
blockchain Technologies very often are
these multi-sided marketplaces
marketplaces are really hard if you
think of any Marketplace that exists you
have to seed ones out of the marketplace
first Uber started with like black cabs
Amazon started with books and they see
the ones out of the marketplace now
you're starting with like four
five-sided marketplaces that's
significantly harder right so this is a
hard hard problem to solve right there
isn't a whole lot of adoption we have 80
million wallet holders period uh uh and
few digital assets are actually on the
blockchain currently right and it's
super complex from a regulatory
perspective so there's a crap ton of
reasons why blockchain is not good there
are some reasons why it is good if
you're going to build something on a
blockchain make sure you utilize one of
these because you have to overcome all
of these
and this is where a lot of like the
bubble type thing comes in right people
try to throw blockchain or
decentralization or tokens at everything
without realizing that you're gonna have
to overcome all of this and especially
now with FTX no one is attracted by the
idea of like blockchain and tokens it's
not a sexy thing
right on the flip side web 2 is really
good at all these
so if you think about like what are
possible applications Emerging Markets
where you don't have centralized
institutions or financial infrastructure
so you have companies like Bello that
that's using stablecoin uh for payments
in Argentina you have like BQ that's
doing supply chain uh tracking and
giving wallets to Farmers
right you have governments that are
exploring using blockchain technology uh
country of Georgia's put its landistry
on land registry on there if you want to
give benefits to your citizens it's a
hell of a lot easier if you can directly
communicate with them and and give them
money to their wallets and see what
they're spending on you have ecosystems
right so we're seeing a lot of
Corporations and consortiums adopting
blockchain and that's on the bottom
there Walmart BMW City but also like in
shipping that's gsbn or equity in Europe
it's an ecosystem for the energy markets
right we're seeing new types of
organizations uh Evan mizono spoke about
git coin but uh Drive is is like an Uber
on the blockchain we'll see if it
actually works Mastodon isn't on a
blockchain but it's this concept of
decentralized uh social media
right you have a lot of uh on the
marketing side now that Brands can't use
cookies because Apple disable them how
do you get in touch with your consumers
without spamming them right so there's a
really interesting use case of using
tokens in nfts for Brands to communicate
directly with users and give them
promotions directly and actually have
direct engagement whereas right now
they're disintermediated by Distributors
by social media by Google Facebook Etc
the metaverse right if you think about
creating open protocols the metaverse is
multiple worlds that need to somehow be
connected how are they connected how can
we create infrastructure to connect
these things
and finally things like smart cities
right so if you think about the idea
that uh we're enabling programmatic
money and programmatic transactions now
everything can become autonomous and
automated in a way that this is actually
viable and feasible
now where are their blockchain bubbles
again uh if you try to decentralize
things but you're not actually
leveraging the fundamental properties of
decentralization right is this something
that uh you know you want multiple
people to be able to come in and out of
uh or is it just like a closed ecosystem
uh you know does eBay need to be or like
does a Nike need to be decentralized why
um same with you know we see a lot of
projects that are tokens just because
they're tokens right uh you you want to
raise money so you sell a token well
what ends up happening is a bunch of
speculators buy your token traded on on
an exchange and you have no control over
your actual token or utility and have
you actually built something of value
right closed platforms again if you're a
closed ecosystem you don't need
something that's permissionless for
people to come in and out you don't need
trust because you can have trust
speculation uh so all the [ __ ] coins and
the algo trading of [ __ ] coins a lot of
the nft world right if you're building
something where the primary value is in
the token going up uh and if you say
that it's social but as soon as the
money goes away no one's using it
anymore you're really just in
speculation now there's a lot of good
things that came out of speculation a
lot of people built a lot of great
technology out of it but it hasn't had
lasting power and ultimately we want to
build things that are leveraging
blockchain to add value right and value
needs to come from The Real World which
means that real people and real
companies need to see value in these
projects
uh and lastly and this is kind of like
uh this is a for now and this is my own
personal opinion so I I think if you
spoke to people six months ago or even
me six months ago if you were building a
web 3 project that was only for web 3
users uh imagining a web through
Universe there was real value here
potentially because there was a lot of
Engagement now that there isn't we're
really seeing that most of the the
application that will have lasting power
are building infrastructure where there
will be some sort of project that's web
3 for the real world or just building
web 3 for the real world period
uh with that I will let [ __ ] continue
thank you Gail
um so now we're going to evaluate like
different verticals
um right now the first one is like um
decentralized Finance
um so um there's a reason why uh we had
the D5 summer first like 2020 uh because
that's where uh you unlock the huge
potential of um the underlying crypto
assets like ethereum and Bitcoin and
create a lot of uh kind of um uh like
dollar value on top and then with
additional dollar value unlocked by
those soccer ball assets some of the
money went to other kind of applications
like aft that's why you have empty after
the D5 summer which is the afd summer is
2021 and the D5 summer is 2020. so it's
extremely important this application
decentral Finance to kind of push the
web3 technology or the crypto technology
forward
um so
um kind of um distinguishing between
like traditional or Central Finance and
decentral finance so what do we know
like Finance today we call it like a
traditional Financial centralized
Finance so there are different uh
basically like a lot of rules like if
you like use like Adam Smith
um kind of a perfect world where
everyone just uh doing things or acting
as an economic agent within the economy
but to their own benefit but by working
towards their own benefit they're
actually benefiting the entire economy
however there's scenarios where like
people or economy agents are like to
become very greedy and they are
maximizing their own self-interest and
harming other agents in the economy
right that's where you tend to have a
lot of economic crisis
um in the past right so that's where a
lot of government have along the history
of like probably like four or 500 years
of History has set up different rules
and regulations Etc to make sure the
human grade doesn't hurt like other of
people losing the economy so all the
different rules and and regulations and
uh it's like manual so I not necessary
can be implemented or executed perfectly
um and uh tend to be kind of racing each
country or the us or like Europe and
it's not very adaptable which means like
you have something new coming out
um it's lagging right it's hard to be
like uh like adapt to to the new
environment
um and also it's fragmented as I
mentioned before within the ecosystem
and decentralized Finance on the other
hand tend to be like although it's very
new I tend to be like Global and
Universal and also program based so it's
programmable and also a set of rule
right if you have traditional financial
side of rule and then I would say like
decision Finance is also a set of rule
except that it's not manual it's more
programmable programmable and also it's
a transparent and right can see it right
so that being said we're actually seeing
this the general Finance given like we
only have like two three years of
history of traditional uh different
Finance we're seeing like a lot of
traction with Central Finance and with
this uh bull to Bear transition we're
actually haven't seen too much of a
crash of designer Finance protocols like
unit sebastia Works Avi and compound
works is the lending and uh and um and
the tax is working however the
centralized Finance however the
centralized Finance who were trying to
attack or get into the crypto space tend
to crash because they're creating new
rules
uh for something new and in the
traditional way how they do things for
the new things or for the new like
technology they tend to fail and they
learn from the failure and they come up
with new regulations so that's a case
for like
um companies like uh uh uh Celsius right
for FTX
um just uh block fight Etc all those
companies are using the centralized way
to apply crypto or something that's
decentralized and now it might work but
you just need a lot of learning and
since manual and adapting to come up
with the perfect way to make sure
there is enough safety
um so where D5 works we have seen I
mentioned earlier uni Swap and Company
although the value went down but the
whole protocol is still working right
the whole mechanism didn't crash
uh we've seen clear use cases for
stablecoin and especially if it's uh
uscc is um
um it's a huge um but you can get us
Dollar on crypto and it's like huge for
like a lot of countries where they have
they won't have access to US dollar but
they don't have access to US dollar
um and use it for uh different scenarios
uh and then we see like payments and the
fact you can program and compose
payments
um uh it's uh pretty powerful
um the payments using the usdc or using
Bitcoin ethereum so we've seen like
clear uh use cases where D5 works and
proven works and did not crash uh during
the market condition
um and we're uh we see like also like uh
D5 creates bubble I did not work oh work
kind of temporarily
um and also one thing that's tricky
about uh crypto is
something that's kind of doesn't work or
like Ponzi scheme it will it will appear
to be working and my work only also for
years like the case for Terra and
Olympus and they have huge traction uh
but it's not sustainable it's more like
Ponzi scheme but when you were like kind
of um back then like a year ago you see
something like so big and so new and
it's actually gaining like a lot of
traction and everything next 100x in
such a short
um kind of a period of time so people
tend to get confused and tend to think
this is just Innovation right uh however
after it's not sustainable so after like
year or two like those things tend to
crash because they're just bubble and
then the old farming like there's so
many protocols like just new protocols
and their whole traction how would they
track people is by giving out their new
tokens and people can your farm and then
they create another protocol or your
farming protocol on top
or um no transparent transfer exchanges
uh where we tend to have uh kind of a
problem
uh without a transition to empty and
Priyanka is gonna
do the empty part
all right so
um is the audio working I guess it is
all right so with respect to nft real
versus bubble where do I get started um
all right let's do a quick recap so this
whole lecture is about signal over noise
so non-fungible tokens have had a very
uh mixed experience in the web 3 space
so far we have had some of the biggest
weirdest projects come out through nfts
so to just extract signal is that this
is a medium of exchange it's just like a
token and that's about it and this is
all about proof of ownership and
provenance and things like that if you
think about it we don't talk about
fungible tokens as intensely as
non-fungible tokens we have different
applications that we talk about like D5
Dows and stuff like that but nfts are
unique in a certain way because we don't
have a real world primitive if you take
a currency not today that is fungible to
some extent but non-fungible is kind of
a relatively new primitive so
um getting the mental models trade would
actually help us build better
applications so if you can have a tool
that can identify anything
in a unique way just like uniquely
identifying any particular object in the
world and this identification is edged
forever what would you do with it
because this is what an nft is it can
uniquely identify anything and it's
going to be written in an immutable
letter so you cannot like
screw around with it there's going to be
a history of its creation deletion who
made it when they made it and stuff like
that so what would you do with a tool
like this is a way to probably think
about nfts in the past to talk about
real applications that we had some of
them were created economy digital
artists didn't have a place to post
their artworks they had to give it to
stock companies like Shutterstock or
adobe and people like that and they took
a huge cut and there was just this whole
middleman issue so now we have created
economy where any digital artist can
post their work without having to like
put an ugly Watermark or something on
top of it and they're going to have
collectors who buy the work for the
address that minted the work for the
provenance and stuff like that now we
also have identity where any on-chain
activity can be bundled and shown as a
person's identity this all goes back to
the previous mental model which we spoke
about which is unique identification and
immutability events indicates there are
so many different concepts trying to
bring nfts into the picture and give
tickets as nft so after the event you
could probably sell it or use it as a
commemorative thing and sell it in a few
years for like a lot of money fantasy
sports we have this company called sore
that was very interestingly famous for
people who follow football and NBA stuff
they did a lot of stuff with
fantasy sports and nfts because it made
sense with the mental model social media
we had lens protocol which built a
protocol on top of which anybody can
build social media apps every comment
every like every post would be
considered as an nft and then you can
start trading it so when you connect
with someone you get you get their nft
in your wallet and
stuff like that in the future anything
that basically could fit into the mental
model could possibly be considered as an
application tokenized real estate is
something that's being considered we had
an event this afternoon with the
blockchain club I'm not sure if you guys
attended
um game assets and virtual lands any
literal matter verse we talk about today
um is considering this whole aspect of
having an immutable decentralized token
server so that nobody can possibly have
like a centralized dictatorship over
these assets and fashion is also is a
very very fast moving industry in fact
the fastest of all they're trying to
adapt these things because as Gil
mentioned customer retention and
identifying who the influencer is and
all the Gen Z Tick Tock influencer
culture is transitioning towards this as
we need to have good relationship with
people who do the marketing and the
fashion brands and stuff like that so
these are all the real stuff to talk
about the bubble we have had extensive
amount of bubbles so far in nfts we have
had random PFE projects making I don't
know thousands of images and selling it
to random people nft theft and Falcon
Works in people randomly stealing images
and minting it to be something else and
the obvious security vulnerability is
that um come with anything that is
related to crypto fishing attacks and
stuff so nfts are prone to a lot of
bubble because this also tends to target
market that is not directly technical
art is fashion industry and people like
that so it has been a relatively more
vulnerable space compared to D5 in the
others but hopefully it would all
decrease and people would build
meaningful stuff in time to come
and over to Phil talk about Dao
all right that was
um so yeah very quick Reaper and recap
what's it down this is a slide from our
from our speaker here
um decentralized autonomous and
organization
um I think that the one thing I don't
agree with with his his definition is he
he forgot the people in here so um you
can't just have like any
um yeah any administrative or functional
structure you do have to have people in
it for for it to be an organization
[Music]
um
yeah that was so I mean in in the Dow
space people really like to believe that
it's completely novel and that we've
never had this before
um we have had this before quite a quite
a long time ago actually
um there are lots of different models
that that have built something that is
uh that is like a Dao before so these
are from some of the readings from from
the Dow class that you had
um we've had hacktivis Collective so
Anonymous they've built something that
is quite similar to a doll just without
boating
um you have collectives
um that that built the Drone together
you have open source software
development projects and even pirate
Crews have had like extensive
participatory decision making so they're
quite similar to Dallas
um
so yeah we can we can learn from the
from the past and we can kind of figure
out what what is actually
um why why my dolls be really helpful
um and uh yeah there there's a long list
of reasons why they might be helpful so
one of them is we we now have internet
native companies um that's that's really
big internet native companies that are
that are linked to a way of of
transferring value natively without
having to go to intermediaries
um we can do very cool things with it if
we if we use that power correctly
um yeah we can leverage all these kind
of crowd-based mechanisms such as
crowdforce crowdsourcing and so on
um it's been discussed in in literature
as distant search so basically being
able to draw on things that are kind of
very very far away from the competence
that you have in your company or in like
whatever organization you've built so
you can you can build some really really
interesting Innovation
um Innovation products
um then there's there's some literature
from from like uh actually the 2000s
that that argues communities are really
good at creating knowledge program
products because there's more trust in
them
um you have higher resistance to
government and governance capture so not
some dictator can come in and just you
know like capture your project and do
Shady things with it as just recently
happened in FTX
um and uh yeah some people argue people
will work for Less because they they
think um
voting is an incentive in itself
and yeah people have hoped that you can
do more participatory decision making
making kind of like a more democratic
a democratic kind of uh yeah
organization and then yeah you can use
incentive mechanisms and hopefully use
all these nice powerful incentives that
you can do for tokens to capture
positive externalities that are created
by a community that you have
um but if you do talk to some people
who've been working in Dallas and who
who really understand the the Dow
ecosystem and who uh yeah have spent a
lot of time there they're usually quite
negative about them and they're usually
they're quite negative for for these
reasons
um so far Dallas are are not working
super well
um they're inefficient they're
ineffective so they they are very slow
um they have frequent breakdowns of
communication internal conflict they
don't handle growth well as a company
that is you know trying to scale and
doesn't doesn't grow well that's a
problem
um if you if you put it down and the VC
funded startup next to each other
because these styles are so inefficient
and ineffective usually the VC funded
startup will win and out compete the Dow
and um so far they've been you know
based on a lot of the successes have
been based on some of the unsustainable
value drivers that we've that we've
discussed before
um including ponsonomics and all these
other things that that currently like is
happening in the crypto space one other
thing that I that I want to highlight is
regulatory Arbitrage so you know just
because you can break the rules that are
happening in certain countries
um that's that's probably not a
sustainable sustainable business model
going forward
um and the big promise of these dolls
was that you make that you make the the
world fairer and more equal and that
hasn't really happened either so most of
the times in in Dallas that are that are
kind of profitable you have VCS or
Founders or some kind of other Insider
holding a lot of the governance tokens a
lot of the tokens that give you some
type of um some type of output
so yeah all in all um Dallas do have a
lot of promise but at the moment as
they're going and then they're not
realizing a lot of it
and we will have to do more research to
figure out whether this is um because of
bad mechanisms um bad technology or if
there's some type of fundamental issue
so um the other thing we have to find
out is what contexts are dolls really
good at so it might be that certain
problems are really really good for
being tackled by Dao or like an online
community and certain or not we don't
know yet the one thing that that seems
to be the case is it's not always the
case that you just put democracy into
something and it's going to be very way
way better than bureaucracies usually
there's a usually there's a reason if we
have an organizational form that's been
working well for 100 years so probably
like those are not just going to replace
everything
um but yeah maybe I'm wrong so I'm going
to be doing some more research on this
and let you know once once I figure it
out
um all right who's gonna take this away
oh Aaron fantastic
all right so to discuss some gaps and
opportunities that we see in blockchain
today
um if you look at
uh just the performance of blockchains
so ethereum running 10 to 15
transactions per second L2 settlement
times and delays just the cost of
running transactions uh you know
multi-dollar gas fees to run really
simple compute the user experience some
wallets
um I don't know how many of you tried
using a wallet my favorite example is
Avalanche where you have uh three
different Avalanche chains and if you
move your tokens to the wrong address
within your own wallet you lose them
okay this could be improved
likewise the developer experience it's
lots of languages fragmentation
solidity and rust are a great place to
start but there are many new languages
coming out
has these other things standardize
you'll be able to start building
marketplaces and marketplaces like the
App Store truly don't exist yet and to
drive further adoption you'll need those
types of marketplaces to make the
experience easy for users we only have
about 80 million wallets today
another kind of Gap is and opportunity
is the regulatory complexity so because
you have different regulations in
different parts of the world and in
particular in the US we don't have
regulations at all but we have lots of
uncertainty it creates
um
kind of risks as you build a new product
just imagine you're building a new
Financial product
now places where you have opportunities
to address some of these gaps right now
I would say most VC funding is going
towards infrastructure that's everything
at the compute layer it's infrastructure
with users it's everything in the
left-hand column here
and
um digital asset tokenization so
um think like things in games and that
sort of thing also digitization of the
physical world so Taylor Swift tickets
right that would be nice if that were
handled better uh developer tooling is
an opportunity again to address the gaps
on the left-hand side user experience
analytics and risk management are really
coupled into the regulatory side of this
thing so it's not just
building things to make The Regulators
happy though that's part of it it's also
you know what happens when you send
tokens to the wrong address how do you
build an insurance policy to prevent
that
and then regulatory Solutions especially
in the zero knowledge proof space you
can use zero knowledge to build
compliance tools without revealing your
data so that could be really helpful in
something like medicine or taxes or what
have you
um so now uh concluding the course and
sort of circling back to our thesis here
you know in web 3 what's a bubble and
what's actually going to be
transformative infrastructure
and you know look the answer is pretty
simple
so just like in web 2 we had a
you know early experiments pets.com
and people learn things from these
experiments and so you had a whole wave
of companies in the.com Crash around the
year 2000 and the late 90s and many of
those companies people laughed at them
because they said oh well who would have
thought about shipping dog food for free
it's expensive it's heavy but then the
next generation of companies learned
from that and builds truly
transformative platforms and
Technologies
so blockchain is in that unique space
where the last generation of companies
you could just kind of release a token
and you then hire some people they sign
up for 4chan they show your token and
you get the token price to go crazy
um there's nowhere in there where
there's real value for the users and so
that's now changing it's changing on the
investment side and so now it's really
simple you want to build a web 3 company
build something that people want and
that was true in web 2 that was true in
web one that was true before the
internet if you're building a product
you build something that people want to
buy now in blockchain we're in this cool
place where lots of early experiments
are failing like right now and so you
can learn from all of them and then go
build new companies but it's early
enough
that most anything that matters actually
hasn't been solved yet we don't have
good wallets we don't have good
developer tooling there's no no good
like name service like DNS I mean ens is
very limited on ethereum
just really basic stuff you'd want
there's no good I want to run a zero
knowledge proof just hit prove and all
the deployment infrastructure happens
a lot of the software is still sort of
academic code so you know if you go on
to AWS and you fire something up on say
Lambda it just runs your code for you in
blockchain it's like start reading white
papers and downloading things off GitHub
and then looking at documentation that's
six months outdated and so all of these
things are problems that can be solved
right now and they're all things that
really add value to the world
so we think it's an exciting time in
blockchain because there's so much to
build and so many of the early failures
have already happened and the space is
well funded and so it's just a unique
time in the space reminds me of the
internet back in the late 1990s and
early 2000s
um with that
we're running this course again next
quarter and we believe that the course
number will be 246 a again that is still
to be confirmed
and it'll be in this room at the same
time on Mondays at 4 30. we've already
been lining up exciting guest speakers
for you so I believe the CEO of elio is
confirmed yes confirmed awesome
from a different state
yeah so CEO of elio flying in to come
talk to you guys and many other exciting
guest speakers in the works if you have
somebody in particular Who You'd like us
to drag to campus because you'd like to
talk with the person
um say it's you know some high level CEO
where you know if you just emailed them
out of the blue and said hey my name is
John well you have spent an hour with me
talking and of course the answer is no
but if you say oh will you come and talk
to a Stanford class and and you know
would you give a guest lecture and then
they go oh yeah oh yeah so if you have
anybody like that and you want us to
bring them to campus let us know and
we'll give it our best shot
um yes you can take this multiple times
for credit so either it will be 246a
again which is what we think or it will
be uh 246 C and D but we're trying to
keep the number of course numbers down
um
what else I think that's the end of the
deck right it is so
um
yeah I guess we have five minutes left
should I open this up to discussion q a
questions
next quarter
like in any way or are they all going to
be new speakers
um so the question is will it be new
speakers next quarter and the answer is
yes
um yeah yeah we're also trying to have
the course be much more Technical and
dive a lot deeper we want to be able to
ask the hard questions so this course
was at a very kind of surface level uh
and we're gonna assume that people have
taken either the technical courses like
sister 51a or have technical background
and really uh get get into the meat of a
lot of the topics
cool any other questions
no okay
um I think just as a closing note
um I want to observe that you all have a
very very special Community here at
Stanford when it comes to blockchain so
my background is I've done several
startups I graduated here with a PhD
I've worked with different startup
accelerators around the country and when
I have these conversations with startup
accelerators every single one of them is
going oh oh we should start a blockchain
program oh
um so how does this work what's a
blockchain oh it's a ledger oh hmm who
do we talk to oh how do we build
companies there oh a16z has a big fund
maybe we should get in on this
and here at Stanford what you have is
one of the top research groups in the
world working on blockchain you've got
the blockchain club that is more
connected than any of the startup
accelerators I've talked to you have
this course you have other course
offerings you have the Stanford
blockchain accelerator
um you know even just the guest lectures
that the blockchain club runs where
they're bringing in all these high-level
people when you go talk to people
outside of this community it's like a
lot of legwork to get those
conversations to happen so given that
the space is so early and there are so
many things to build in blockchain if
you want to start a company you want to
build something new you've got ideas I
would just say go for it because if it
works great if it doesn't work you'll be
an expert in this field that's like
growing really quickly so um so just a
thought use the community you have here
everybody who runs the course is happy
to help you out and come to the
blockchain club events come here next
quarter
um anything else I should plug guys any
you know we've plugged everything okay
great so thanks for coming to the class
this corner and hopefully we'll see you
in the winter